Preattentive processing taps into our automatic processes of
vision and perception.
When preattentive processing occurs,
we are able to instantly recognize an element in a visualization.
It's the same reason why this blue bar becomes instantly apparent in
this forest of orange bars.
Here I'm using color, in particular, hue as preattentive attribute.
I could also use color intensity to create the same effect.
Here two bars pop out from the page.
So color hue and color intensity can be used as preattentive attributes.
But there are also other preattentive attributes that can,
we can use to highlight information or to lead the eye in visualizations.
In Colin Ware's book Information Visualization Perception for
Design, he describes four general categories for these attributes.
And they are color, form, movement and spatial position.
We can change the form of objects, such as their line width, curvature, size or,
in this case, the shape.
Movement is another form of preattentive processing.
For these squares, I'm using a flicker effect to draw attention to one of them.
You might have similar fade ins or
fade outs for portions of your visualization that are interactive or
those that highlight particular data values or trends in a visualization.
Finally, spacial position can be employed as preattentive attribute.
You might find this useful for
drawing the eye towards titles, legends, or annotations.
For more examples of preattentive processing check out the links in
the instructor notes.
As a side note, preattentive attributes can be used together but
they may achieve different results.
Here, color and form are used.
Notice that form either a square or
a circle is randomly distributed throughout the grid.
But the color attribute creates a clean boundary down the grid.
In this example, the reverse is true.
Color is randomly distributed to shapes throughout this grid, but
notice that form does not do the partitioning of the grid as well as in
this previous example.
In this second example, the horizontal shape boundary is masked by color or hue.